- I went to the Harry Styles concert
like two years ago.
- Ah, you went to one?
- But, like, you've experienced that joy.
I've never been to a concert.
So I'm just saying.
- My heart.
- Welcome to "Stacks".
The show where every vote counts.
Today, six teens must
decide who gets to win
a pair of Coachella tickets.
The players will have
four rounds of discussion.
After each round, there
will be blind voting.
One gold brick equals one vote.
At the end of the game,
the person with the tallest
stack wins the prize.
This is "Stacks".
(cash register noise)
(funky music)
What's up, my fellow teens?
Your favorite Coachella dance?
(beat-boxing)
Round one, each player
will get one gold brick.
They'll have six minutes to discuss
who they think should take the prize.
And go.
- Okay. Okay.
I'm gonna just go first.
I'm a college student.
I don't have a job, so if I wanna
buy Coachella tickets,
there's no way of affording it.
My parents, they support me
but only to a minimum.
I wanna have fun.
I'm a teen and I feel like Coachella
would be a great option.
- So I'm Jayan. I'm actually from Germany.
So I'm only here for three months.
I'm just doing a gap year.
I can't work.
I'm not allowed to,
so I have no way of making any money,
and I spend all my money
on just coming here.
So that would be really nice addition
to go to Coachella too.
- I've never been able to
see Ye or Billie or Harry.
But all three of those artist, they're all
extremely important to
who I am today, so yeah.
- I know a lot of the
headliners at Coachella.
I felt like I came in here
looking like a Harry Styles stan.
- Well, I'm also a college student.
I work at Whole Foods and
I'm trying to save up.
I have to pay for my own food,
my own car, even my tuition.
And I don't really have a lot of money.
I'd love to go to Coachella.
I'd rather go to Stagecoach, but-
(all laughing)
- All right, my name's Shayaun.
Well, I'm currently a
senior in high school.
I'm into music. I like it.
I wouldn't say I'm an expert in the field.
You know, my sister's a really big fan
cause I'd probably take
her for her birthday.
Yeah. I've just never been
to a concert or a music
festival of any sort.
- Have any of you guys been
to like an outdoor festival?
- No.
- Okay, me either.
- I am broke because I went
to Lollapalooza in Chicago.
- Oh, you did?
- And now I have no money. So.
- How would you guys get there?
- I don't even have a car
because it's too expensive.
I just rented one for one weekend,
to drive around and come here.
Sleep in the car or something.
- That'd kinda be fun though.
I mean, it would be an
experience for sure.
- Okay. Time's up.
All right.
Let's let the voting begin.
Each player will vote
for who they think should win the prize.
But, there's a catch.
If all six players vote for themselves,
the game is over and no one wins.
- He said he's from Germany.
I'm guessing he flew out here,
so his plane ticket is expensive.
(intense string music)
- He seems to be the
most genuine about it.
- This is a contest, not a charity.
Don't hate the player, hate the game.
(intense string music)
- I still don't know
much about anyone here.
So I'm thinking that this
would be a good idea.
- Please open your eyes
in three, two, one.
Open.
- Wow.
- Good stuff.
- That is good stuff.
- Thank you guys. Thank you guys.
- [Q] Respect, respect.
- Thanks bro.
(clinking)
- Okay. We're heating
things up with round two.
But, the voting's a little different.
In round two, only
players who currently have
stacks will receive two
more gold bricks for voting.
But, all players can
participate in the discussion.
Four minutes. Go.
- So who do you guys wanna see?
- Kanye and Baby Keem.
- Yeah.
- Have to see Kanye, yeah.
- Daniel Caesar.
Snoh Aalegra.
- Steve Lacy.
- Oh my God.
And it's Brockhampton's last performance.
- I have to say for my girls,
for sure Doja Cat and Megan.
- Oh yes, Doja Cat. You're so right.
- Harry and Billie, yeah.
- Harry?
- Yeah. I am a huge Harry fan.
- I mean, I did perform
a Harry Styles song.
- Oh you did?
- In elementary school,
in a talent show, so.
- So you already knew?
- Yeah, like an OG One Direction fan.
- I make music myself too.
That goes in direction of Stromae,
which is why I really want to see him.
- Okay.
- Cause he just inspired
me for my own stuff.
- Yeah.
- Well, I could see that
we all can go all days
and see somebody every day.
- Of course.
- Each one of us will
make the most out of it,
which is good.
- Whoever voted for themselves,
I just wanna get back in.
(all laughing)
- If I were to go to Coachella,
it would be this one.
It's cause I know a lot of the headliners.
- Bout to say, the headliners is never
gonna be like this again.
So it's like,
this is like a once opportunity.
- For this round,
players can use their two gold bricks
to vote for any player.
Even those without a stack.
- I felt bad.
But also I had to do one for myself
cause this is a competition.
(intense string music)
- I definitely feel bad
for some of the other contestants,
but I didn't come here for nothing.
(intense string music)
- Open your eyes in three, two, one.
You're back in the game guys.
- Yeah.
- Awesome.
- Thanks guys.
- Jayan and Shayaun,
you guys are bricked up.
- Dang bro.
(clinking)
- It's the start of round three.
Things are gonna switch up a little bit.
You're voting on someone
who you think should
lose their entire stack.
- Ouch.
- Yikes.
- Oh my god.
- Begin.
- What do we even talk about?
- This is devastating.
- When everyone's so nice
and sweet, this is tough.
So I really had a tough time.
I was really struggling.
- I don't wanna do this.
- I mean like, I feel so scared right now.
- To be fair, there's
only like one round left.
There's not that much
room to recoup yourselves.
So I'm just saying.
- The person I'm dating really wants to go
and we have like no money.
So it'd be great to go for free.
- I mean, just the feeling of being
at a concert is like- I went
to the Harry Styles concert
like two years ago before
the pandemic started.
- Ah, you went to one?
- It was like one of the best feelings
like I've ever had.
- Pure joy.
- Yeah. It's literally like pure joy.
Since COVID, it's been like really
hard on like a lot of people.
- Yeah. Especially us college students.
Oh my gosh.
- Yeah. But like you've
experienced that joy.
I've never been to a
concert or a music festival.
I mean, Coachella is like pretty much
the most iconic music festival.
So that'd be kinda sick, my first thing.
- I'm in to win it
and I'm not gonna go down without a fight.
- Also like I worked so much back
in Germany just to come here
and it would be so nice to
just like finish my trip
off with going to Coachella.
- My heart.
Are you ever gonna come back?
- I hope so.
But like, I'm not allowed
for the next two years now
because of the visa things.
And like, if they let me
in at some point again,
I want to, but-
- I see.
- But don't they have like concerts
like Coachella where you're from?
- Nothing like that.
They have like small festivals
with like German artists and stuff.
- Dang.
- Well, I'm devastated. This sucks.
- All right. Time is up.
Friendships will be broken.
Enemies will be made.
On that note, let the voting begin.
Players who currently
have stacks will vote
for who they think should
lose their entire stack.
(intense string music)
- He came for me after I said went
to the Harry Styles concert.
- She's already been to a concert.
I love you. And I vibe with you.
But, I'm sorry.
- I had to do those that had less to lose.
- I like the guy, but right
now he's my biggest threat.
So I have to do what I have to do.
- Hey, it's me.
The bearer of bad news.
Unfortunately Shayaun, you
were voted the most and lost.
- Oh, 100 percent.
I knew it was gonna happen.
I knew I was gonna lose
my stack in round three.
- I did vote for Shayaun and
I felt really bad doing it.
He was like my biggest threat.
I just felt bad for voting
for him, for voting him out.
- But it's not over for you, Shayaun.
- Okay.
- Shayaun lost his stack,
but now has the opportunity
to redistribute his bricks.
He can give his bricks
to any player who he thinks is deserving.
(intense string music)
- Oh.
(all laughing)
- Jayan, you got the hookup.
- I'm just thankful.
Thank you. I love you.
- Hey, it's not over though.
(clinking)
All right.
This is the last and final round.
But I'm not gonna tell
you what's gonna happen
with the voting. And shoot.
- Okay. Can I put you on the
spot and ask you why you gave-
- Yeah, you can.
I mean, I'm not gonna lie,
I saw him as a threat.
- (all laughing)
- But, you know,
at the end of the day, I loved his story.
You know, he's from Germany.
And like, he seems really into
the not as popular artists, you know,
like he knows his stuff.
- I just wanna ask real quick.
What artists are you
like most excited for?
- Stromae, just because
he influenced my music.
Disclosure and, of course, Finneas.
I always like watch him and try to
copy the things he does.
And, of course, the big ones.
I do like Billie Eilish and Harry Styles.
- What about you guys?
- Kanye, cause he showed
me what's possible as an
African American.
Billionaire, he's amazing.
And a genius.
Harry. He showed me how to be expressive,
how to treat others.
And then Billie,
she just showed me what you
can achieve at a young age
and what's possible and whatnot so.
- You're so right.
- Treat people with kindness.
- Wait, why are you here again? Sorry.
- I'm here because I make music.
I just wanna get to know people.
I connect with people here.
- So if we let you win,
you'll take us backstage when you perform.
- Definitely I will.
- (all laughing)
- Sounds good, sounds good.
- Okay. Time's up.
Here is the final voting rule.
Players can move one brick
from any stack to another.
Only players who currently have
stacks are allowed to vote.
(intense string music)
- He has a couple bricks to lose.
- He's never been to a concert.
He deserved at least one.
- I gave him one the first round
So now I'm gonna be
selfish and give it to me.
I'm so sorry.
- It was a very close game.
Y'all ready?
- No.
- Open your eyes in three, two, one.
(all applauding)
(cash register noise)
- Congratulations.
Here are your Coachella tickets.
- Thank you so much.
(all applauding)
- I absolutely didn't expect it.
The moment I won, I was so happy
But somehow, I feel a bit bad
for the other people as well.
No matter what stories you have.
I think everybody deserved
it the same amount.
(exciting music)
(all laughing)